make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video we are going to explain the
character of red hulk now the reason why
we're doing this
is one because i miss doing character
explanations and two because i believe
it's jacob h
is one of our higher tier patrons and if
you're a high enough tier on patreon you
can actually request to have
a character explanation video made or a
beyond omega level video
made and if you're even higher you can
actually get both so jacob requested
that we do a video on red hook explained
and that's what we're going to do
so red hulk or i guess general
thunderbolt ross uh first appeared in
marvel comics with the incredible hulk
number one in may of 1962. of course he
was created like most people back then
by stan lee and jack kirby but here's
the funny thing the origins of
thunderbolt ross like a lot of
characters in marvel are just kind of
scattered all over the place
specifically in the incredible hulk
number one uh tales to astonish number
61
and uh the incredible hulk number 291
now
another thing that kind of goes on here
is something called control and control
was a was something that showed up in
conspiracy number one which was this
interesting
line of comics that marvel did back in
1998 uh that was made that was done by
dan abnet but uh for this particular
purpose uh we're gonna focus on on those
original three issues that that we had
mentioned
right so the idea of thunderbolt ross in
terms of his creation at the hands of
stan lee and jack kirby was that much
like a lot of the comics back then
stanley did recognize the idea that the
incredible hulk was kind of like this
giant green rage monster but more so
than that stan lee was all about the
idea of focusing on the human element of
characters in the sense that who are
they beyond like whatever fantastic
powers they happen to have
and so where where bruce banner was kind
of this you know dr jekyll and mr
hyde-esque character
stan lee thought it was really
interesting to create a villain that was
basically just
a man there was nothing really special
about him he didn't have any kind of
superpowers or anything like that
it was just kind of like mankind against
like it's it's almost warring
nature right it's kind of what what the
incredible hulk represented and so when
thunderbolt ross was initially
introduced to us
uh in the incredible hulk number 291
we're given the story the thunderbolt
ross actually comes from
a family of people who were involved in
the military and it was very much a
source of pride for thunderbolt ross to
basically join up with what was the army
air corps at the time in the 1940s
eventually that became the air force but
the army air corps at the time
and then basically like rose through the
ranks exceedingly fast now
one of the things that stan lee didn't
really give us a lot of is whether or
not it was based largely on his
abilities or on his family history
right because i have to believe like
most things in the world the military
kind of allows you to move up in the
ranks based on your own family history
right so the stronger your family ties
with the military uh and the more
involved they were the easier i think it
is for you to move up i don't really
have any evidence to support that i'm
not a military man myself but it's
something that i always kind of believed
to be true just based on my own my own
work experience
but regardless during world war ii
general thunderbolt ross actually moved
up to the role of a captain
and fought in the pacific theater but
one of the big things that came out of
thunderbolt ross came with regards to a
concept called control
and control was given to us as this
post-world war
ii era i would say kind of think tank
slash group now control was basically a
handful of guys right so
uh basically military officials that
worked on the side of
really worked alongside bolivar trask
and looked at the idea of basically
trying to stop future crises before they
took place now the notion of control
itself was actually taken by the federal
government
and rolled into what would become
project wide awake with the rise of the
mutant population right of course that
was headed largely by henry peter
guyrick but for the most part control
didn't last
super long uh it ended up being
disbanded more or less and of course the
guy who
created it uh general edwin harrison was
kind of thrown away kind of you know
blackballed as a crazy guy
but the big takeaway from from
thunderbolt ross came with the fact that
he was stationed at the los alamos
research facility in new mexico of
course most of you guys are familiar
with this as the place where bruce
banner became the incredible hulk for
the very first time
and the idea behind this was that
thunderbolt ross had been consistently
presented to us
as very much in being a kind of prideful
man right in the sense that
his assignment here at the at the
nuclear research facility
kind of pissed him off right it was it
took place before the events of the
korean war and kind of ran through the
korean war and after the korean war
and because of the fact that he had
maine made such a name for himself in
the sense those under his command had
actually given him the nickname
thunderbolt because he just kind of flew
in like a strike of lightning right his
ability to fly jets different things
like that uh that it seemed like his
entire
entirely decorated military career had
kind of fizzled out with him just
working a desk job at some research
facility somewhere now of course he also
spent time with brian banner but one of
the big things that came out of this is
that his wife
karen had only given him one daughter
betty ross and it died when betty was in
her teens the other thing behind this is
that because betty ross had basically
been brought over to uh to thunderbolt
ross
in order to you know have a parent to
raise her he actually ended up shuffling
her off to a
to a boarding school and then once she
became an adult she ended up coming back
now
this sort of wraps around and bookends
into the incredible hulk number one
when you have her encountering bruce
banner for the first time alongside
thunderbolt ross
and and ross's distaste for bruce banner
initially started out as something
innocuous something small
because of the fact that bruce banner
was the one who was running the nuclear
project and it kind of pissed off
pissed off thunderbolt ross because in
his mind it was a military project
therefore a military official should be
running it and because of his decorated
history he felt like it should have been
him right so
you know a lot of that pride kind of
coming into foray and the fact that you
ended up having
uh bruce banner basically pushing you
know rick jones out of the way when the
the
the initial gamma bomb was supposed to
go off and then being exposed to those
and becoming the incredible hulk as we
know
it basically laid the groundwork for
thunderbolt ross to go directly after
after bruce banner trying to figure out
what in the world was going on now the
other thing that we had going on here
was a man by the name of glenn talbott
who at the time when he was stationed at
desert base was basically a security
chief and a major uh but of course he
would go on to become the husband of
betty ross and you know at a future
point in time but
as far as bruce banner himself and the
relationship between him and general
thunderbolt ross the other part of
ross's frustration
with banner writing the show is that
banner didn't really live up to how ross
saw him or saw a man should be that he
wasn't really masculine in the way that
ross believed a man should be
this and the fact that betty was
actually becoming attracted to uh to
bruce banner which kind of pissed him
off because he always felt like uh
like betty should basically marry a
military man effectively led ross to
this place whereby bruce banner was
essentially everything he stood against
right and and in a lot of ways banner
was just kind of this guy who received
this unfair treatment at a man who was
really just unhappy with his life
thunderbolt ross looking back at his
career and seeing how it all kind of
seemed to coalesce with what was
basically a desk job and seemed to kind
of take away from all of his great
military achievements
along with you know betty ross becoming
attracted to banner banner not quite
being the man that general thunderbolt
ross thought he should be uh would
basically led to banner becoming just
this target
really just this overall vitriol in the
fact that general thunderbolt ross just
didn't really like his life right and so
when bruce banner became the incredible
hulk initially nobody really knew that
he was the hulk except for rick jones
right he was the only person that never
really found out there did come a point
in the old uh the old incredible hulk
stories where it was believed that the
hulk was killed and this led to rick
jones basically telling uh
thunderbolt ross and and uh and glenn
talbott and betty ross who the
incredible hulk actually was that it was
banner and this is what pissed off ross
because banner had seemingly gone from
this man
who was every ounce you know kind of a
weakling effectively you know kind of a
coward
in the eyes of ross to a man that
basically toppled him right there and it
just it was like this thorn in his mind
that he couldn't quite get out and so
the result was that he became the
singular focus
of ross's interest right ross tracked
him down in almost every conceivable way
and these this this kind of early
relationship right the idea of the
incredible hulk wanted to be left alone
general thunderbolt ross constantly
tracking him down was a mainstay
throughout
all of the early incredible hulk stories
right this goes all the way back to the
incredible hulk number 124
it goes into the incredible hulk 145 the
incredible hulk number 158
and you had these different things that
took place whereby
you kind of saw these moments where the
hulk might get some bit of a reprieve
in the sense that ross had kind of taken
pleasure in the fact that betty ross had
actually ended up marrying glenn talbott
it was always kind of this
undertone right in the sense that betty
was constantly being lied to by her
father and saying well all i want to do
is cure the incredible hulk the reality
is that he wanted to kill him right he
wanted to kill him get rid of him or at
the very least hand him over and just
kind of like break his body down and
have him turn into a super soldier but
there was never really anything
altruistic about the desire of general
thunderbolt ross to find the incredible
hulk now by this point
specifically with the incredible hook
issue number 159
steve ingleheart had taken over the
title right and we talked about the the
you know some of the importance of his
run
uh in our video on the incredible hulk
explain at least i think we did a
reworked video i don't remember if we
did an updated video from the original
one that we did that was like nine
minutes long back when i first started
the channel
uh but what you ended up getting here in
this this steve engelhardt run that ran
between 159
and uh 171 is you had general
thunderbolt ross who made a deal with
the abomination and the abomination at
least the idea of it was that it would
basically track down
uh the incredible hulk and it would
capture the incredible hulk but
ultimately of course we know the
abomination
failed and so this led to thunderbolt
ross forming a team of hulk busters
inside canada of course it was done you
know with with permission of canada's
department
h but with that having happened this
team was basically
led uh by a man by the name of colonel
jack ambrose now colonel jack and
brewster was basically captured
alongside the president of the united
states and general thunderbolt ross
uh by the soviets of course this story
kind of taking place during the cold war
is one of the reasons why you saw that
kind of story happening because of the
fact that the cold war was very much a
significant thing
and marvel back during that point in
time running up until about the 80s or
so
uh really kept some pretty strong ties
to real world events as they were
happening at the time that's one of the
issues of the cold war is it really
permeated every facet of of american and
soviet and even worldwide culture
everything from you know mutually
assured destruction stories all the way
up to just how like soviets are a threat
right communism all you know all that
kind of stuff uh the fact that that
general thunderbolt ross had been
captured by the russians was a massive
source of embarrassment and while he was
eventually freed this led to talbot
being
captured by the russians which of course
led betty ross to believe that general
talbot had died and then it kind of
pissed her off and pushed her further
away from her father now
instead of identifying this as a direct
result of what
general thunderbolt ross had done and
the fact that his obsession with causing
a
capturing the hulk had led him to this
place instead like many stories before
it he basically pointed the finger at
the incredible hulk and said if he
didn't exist
none of this would be a problem and so
this was the kind of storytelling that
you saw that basically pushed general
thunderbolt ross
further and further in his pursuit of
capturing the hulk now the reality of
this is that steve ingelhart had
actually left the title before this
particular plot thread was wrapped up
and so with issue number 179
lynn wine came over the title where he
would basically write until issue 1 uh
issue 220 and what's probably considered
one of the most celebrated incredible
hulk runs of all time but the idea here
is that len wine kind of wrapped up
these threads in order to sort of make
the title his own and then just kind of
took off with it from there
by and large the the idea of thunderbolt
ross for the most part
didn't really change and this wasn't
really anything to do with with the fact
that it was a dislike of thunderbolt
ross for len wine but more because
wine wanted to kind of introduce new
concepts right so that's why you saw
like wolverine being bought in when you
saw
the incredible hulk making his way to
canada different things like that uh but
for thunderbolt ross himself one of the
big things that came out of it is that
he was basically reduced to having a
nervous breakdown that after being
basically removed from the project green
skin as it was called uh
and in the entirety of the hulkbuster
base they didn't that ross ended up
suffering like a total nervous breakdown
now eventually he came under the care of
doc sampson
and that served the purpose of basically
saying hey you know look he's he's kind
of being sorted out here uh but for the
most part
between this the the you know capture at
the hands of the soviets all these
things that kind of led to the fact that
he didn't quite feel like the soldier
that he once was
all led to him fully pushing headlong
into the idea that the incredible hulk
basically needed to be captured right
the incredible hulk needed to not just
be captured
but to be killed now again a lot of the
major plot threats focusing on ross
really came with the incredible hulk
issue number 262
is when a lot of this stuff started now
this really goes into what is considered
to be
the single most celebrated run or really
two runs of the incredible hulk the
first one being done by bill mantlow and
the second one being done by peter david
now we've talked about the significance
of these stories
in the sense that unlike lin wine or
steve inglehart or even stan lee and
jack kirby
this kind of notion of the incredible
hulk embodying stories with flights of
fantasy and things like that were really
removed and instead it was focusing
largely
on the human element of the incredible
hulk introducing things like multiple
personality disorder the idea that the
incredible hulk is a physical
manifestation of the abuse that bruce
banner suffered at the hands of his
father brian banner those were all
major plot threads that came with the
incredible hulk line of comics as was
written by bill mantlow
and built on by peter david but as for
general thunderbolt ross himself
things actually got really cool for his
character and so starting in the
three-part story to hunt the hulk the
family that dies together and sunset of
a samurai uh bill manlow introduced
probably one of the most significant
events to happen in the incredible hulk
mythos with the death of general talbot
and the idea behind this
is that with general talbot himself
following the nervous breakdown of
thunderbolt ross general talbot was the
one who was put in charge
of gamma base and the idea was that
general talbot would effectively use his
resources
to hunt down the incredible hulk and
almost pick up the slack of thunderbolt
ross and a lot of this was based on the
fact that betty ross had basically
already established she was still in
love with bruce banner and it actually
divorced general talbot and so in the
aftermath of this general talbot
actually committed treason and then was
ultimately killed in battle with the
incredible hulk himself and so going
into
uh the incredible hulk issue number 262
and following the death of talbot that
this kind of
furthered the idea of the intention of
thunderbolt ross to track down the hulk
and to take him out and so where general
thunderbolt ross couldn't really be
given the resources
uh to basically hunt down the hulk
proper and a lot of this was due to the
fact that congress was devoting
resources to other things as well as
general thunderbolt ross's mini failed
attempts what the president ended up
doing was putting general thunderbolt
ross in charge of a think tank that
would basically allow general
thunderbolt ross to track down the hole
the problem with this is that in issues
278 and 279
this entire plan by the president that
was basically formed by thunderbolt
ross was essentially destroyed when you
ended up having it established that the
incredible hulk could maintain his own
personalities his own
intelligence so on and so forth and the
fact that banner was basically able to
maintain his own identity when he
transformed into the hulk this led
to the president of the united states
basically pardoning the incredible hulk
of all of his past defenses and so what
you ended up having was general
thunderbolt ross who was in charge of
something called project earthball which
basically led to him
intentionally committing treason by
freeing the abomination who had already
been
been held in stasis by the federal
government and then working alongside
aim
managed to pull it off the problem is
that of course the abomination was
basically defeated by the incredible
hulk and then when the hulk forced
general thunderbolt ross to admit his
actions in front of his daughter that
this pushed betty even further away and
closer into the arms of banner and so
what this did was leave thunderbolt ross
in a state of complete and total
disgrace regarding his historical
military career and he basically just
kind of ended up becoming a wanderer but
for the most part
this became one of the most important
aspects of thunderbolt ross's character
because much like we had seen with the
the storytelling of bill manlow where he
focused on the human side of the
incredible hulk he did the exact same
thing with thunderbolt ross and it was
kind of an answer to the question
what happens when all of his misdeeds
and all the terrible things that he done
all in an effort to capture the hulk
basically came to fruition and so when
that when it all kind of hit the fan he
was left
as almost kind of a shell of his former
self right he had already lost his wife
in a future at a previous point in time
now he's lost his daughter he's
effectively lost his career but he
seemingly had lost
everything one of the big issues though
is that despite this work that bill
manlow had put into the incredible hulk
uh by the mid-1980s jim shooter had
worked out a deal
with mattel in order to create toys for
marvel comics the problem is that mattel
wanted an event in order to market these
toys and so marvel ended up creating
marvel superheroes the problem is that
the work that the that had been done on
the incredible hulk and even general
thunderbolt ross and characters like
that uh was kind of wiped away to some
degree
by alan milgram and depending on who you
talked to some people loved the work he
did
others hated it but the idea of general
thunderbolt ross is that he had this
sort of redemption story
in the sense that between uh the
incredible hulk issue number 320 running
all the way up to issue number 330 in
this 10 11 part series that you ended up
having thunderbolt ross who basically
showed up
at the wedding of bruce spanner and
betty ross and that the intention was to
basically stop the wedding from
happening what you ended up getting was
the introduction of this kind of
living electricity sentient energy
called zacks uh that had the intention
of like trying to destroy
well you know doing what villains do the
idea was that thunderbolt ross had
actually stepped in
and basically sacrificed his life to
lead to the defeat of zacks
now in this sacrifice this kind of
redemption story the thunderbolt ross
had basically admitted he was wrong
about everything with regards to bruce
banner that he really was a great guy
that he had to basically trust his
daughter that his daughter knew
a great man when she saw him and that in
this last moment he basically died in
the arms of his daughter right he died
in the arms of betty ross and so for the
most part
this saw the vanishing of of general
thunderbolt ross for quite some time in
fact for about 30 issues or so for 36
issues we didn't really see him he did
come back in
the incredible hulk issue number 366 but
then for the most part we didn't really
see him
after that until we got to the
incredible hulk number 456 at least not
really anything of note he was just part
of the military and was just part of you
know basically there and that was
essentially it now
one of the reasons or at least i kind of
have to assume the reason for this was
because
by that point we were in the peter david
run starting in the 1990s and peter
david took a lot of
emphasis off of villains that have been
around for a long long time
if they didn't really seem to serve a
useful purpose to the stories he wanted
to tell and for the most part the
general thunderbolt ross didn't really
seem to fill that role i mean he just
did some things but a lot of stories
were based on like the leader or
or like abomination or other characters
that we were aware of or even just kind
of building up on the incredible hulk
mythos itself kind of involving a lot of
other characters that were going around
the other part of this is that we were
getting into the 1990s we were talking
about the comic bus
and so for the most part there wasn't
really a lot of room to tell stories
involving characters villains or
otherwise that really didn't draw a lot
of fanfare
and because comics in the 1990s were
just super high octane and super fast
paced there wasn't really a whole lot of
room to focus on somebody like
thunderbolt ross who didn't really have
any powers and whose only real
ally was the us military that he could
use to track down the hulk
not when you were standing in the face
of like the abomination or you were
standing in the face of the leader
or any of these other super powered
beings out there that could be used to
create just
super high intense stories and so what
we ended up getting was basically going
into the mid 2000s
with the launch of the incredible hulk
vol 2. and this basically saw the return
of thunderbolt ross but not really the
way that we intended so with greg pack
taking over the incredible hulk line of
comics and what's arguably the single
most popular run of the incredible hulk
in the history of the entire character
uh we ended up seeing a series of events
take place right planet hulk world war
hulk different things like that
but the idea was to actually kind of
introduce a secondary concept that was
basically new something that we hadn't
really seen before
and it really kind of happened as a
result of two ideas coalescing at the
same time so in an interview with the
washington post with writer jeff loeb
jeff lopez stated the idea for
for red hulk kind of indirectly came
from him and ed mcginnis the fact that
ed mcginnis wanted to draw the
incredible hulk and that they had kind
of had this idea where like the watcher
would show up or something like that and
the incredible hulk would just get
pissed off and punch him and the reason
for that was to establish that the
incredible hulk truly was the strongest
character there was right there would be
some story arc that would take place
well the incredible hulk would basically
fight against all the superheroes on
earth
and come out on top right and basically
just kind of show to the reader yes the
incredible hulk is still the strongest
guy there around that same time
joe casada had actually either come up
with the idea himself or
used the idea that was pitched in the
1970s with regards to the incredible
hulk tv show to have a red version of
the whole
that was basically uninhibited right it
was just kind of a mindless monster
that wasn't really didn't really have to
deal with the struggles of like bruce
banner keeping him in check or anything
along those lines and so these two ideas
effectively came together
with the hulk number one and this was
something that kind of came in the
aftermath of the world war hulk event
that where bruce spanner had basically
been
locked away inside of a prison uh three
miles below
the original facility where he was
exposed to gamma radiation that a new
hulk book was launched there was
basically one of mystery now the funny
thing about this
is that people had looked at this and i
remember going through forums and
checking this out
people had looked at this and they'd
seen what that it was jeff loeb writing
it and a lot of people seemed to be
somewhat disillusioned at the outset
because they were coming out of jeff
loeb's wolf reign run uh which depending
on which fan you talked to
was not super well received but the
overall gist is that for quite some time
we never got an answer to who the red
hulk was instead
the red hulk just showed up on the scene
and then was just attacking various
heroes he was going or
even various characters right he was
going after windigo right just just
characters that were traditionally
you know villains of the uh of the
incredible hulk one of the more
significant things that red hulk did was
actually murder the abomination and it
was really kind of jeff loeb and and
ed mcginnis's way of saying look like
this guy is not to be trifled with
right like the abomination has given the
incredible hulk a run for his money
multiple times over the years now the
red hulk just killed him this in the
fact that the red hulk was shown to be
somebody of military strategy somebody
with some great history
looking in hindsight the clues were
always there right but for the most part
we were all kind of wrapped up in the
story and not really able to figure out
the fact that it was actually
thunderbolt ross that and the fact that
thunderbolt ross have been missing in
comics from
up to that point about a 156 issues
really kind of
made him sort of out of sight out of
mind what you end up getting here are
some events where like uh the the red
hulk is basically brought
together alongside alongside a bunch of
other heroes in a group called the
offenders which is designed to be the
antithesis to the defenders uh he ended
up stealing like the the cosmic power of
the silver surfer
took the silver surfer surfboard killed
a whole bunch of people they were pretty
they were pretty wild right pretty nuts
and and pretty wild but while that was
going on the next clue that we got
in relation to the nature of the
character was red she-hulk and so it was
really kind of building and brewing and
going into multiple things until we
ended up getting into the world war
hulks event whereby we learn that the
red hulk is actually thunderbolt ross
who had been returned that working
alongside the intelligentsia which is
kind of a criminal think tank
organization that's headed by modoc the
general thunderbolt ross had actually
worked alongside bruce banner and that
bruce banner was instrumental in the
death of thunderbolt lost now the whole
idea behind this was to basically throw
fans off the scent right that were fans
were slowly starting to pick up on the
idea that general thunderbolt ross was
actually the red hulk this was designed
to say no he's not either right to kind
of basically eliminate people
who could have been the red hulk that's
why it's one of the reasons why you saw
characters like abomination killed was
one part to establish the power of the
red hulk but to also say
red hulk's not some new version of the
abomination and so this kind of this
sort of pattern happened
consistently across the board but of
course we also ended up learning things
like the general thunderbolt ross who
died was a life model decoy the
revelation at red hulk is
actually general thunderbolt ross and
that's when things changed drastically
with jeff loeb leaving the hulk series
and then in turn jeff parker taking over
as writer we actually saw the red hulk
because of his popularity
being rolled over into more stories and
in fact he actually ends up siding
alongside captain america
and then eventually joins the avengers
you get to the heroic age story in 2010
where you basically end up seeing the
hood trying to capture the infinity
stones and and basically a new version
of the infinity watch all the
earth-based is formed by captain america
and the red hulk actually gets the power
stone right so you saw these small
little things taking place
one of the bigger things to come out of
this because the red hulk's ability to
siphon off energy of other people was
one of his mainstays marvel shook things
up a bit by toying with the idea that it
had actually been taken away but where
it was initially restored
this kind of revelation came out of it
in saying that the ability of the red
hulk to siphon the energy of others was
actually quote unquote killing general
thunderbolt ross and so the result of
this is that he couldn't transform back
into his thunderbolt ross form anymore
and it was basically a way for marvel to
kind of get rid of the old hat
general thunderbolt ross stories to
basically tell fans we're not going back
to the age of comics where like the
incredible hooks on the run and
thunderbolt ross is trying to track him
down that red hulk is basically
here to stay and it made sense because
red hulk was just proved to be so
popular at that point in time people
loved him and they didn't want him to go
anywhere and so by the time he got into
2012
you ended up getting a kind of a kind of
team called the thunderbolts which
differentiated from the original version
that we saw that was led by baron helmut
zemo
this one kind of operated of its own
accord and included general thunderbolt
ross as the red hulk
the problem with this is that by the
time you got into the lead up to the
events of secret wars right like most of
the characters that we saw
at that point in time marvel was
basically phasing things out and marvel
was kind of marvel has
this sort of giant checklist right in
the background not literally but more
metaphorically which characters stay and
which characters go
and while the red hulk proved to be
pretty popular i kind of have to believe
that because the new incredible hulk
film was a mainstay in the mcu even if
people weren't super received to it you
know with edward norton going into the
incredible hulk's involvement
in the avengers movies themselves the
the main mcu story uh played by mark
ruffalo the idea was that there really
didn't seem to be much emphasis
on the red hulk himself and so by the
time you got into civil war 2 2016
you got into the captain america run by
tadahasi coates red hulk was basically a
background character already been
incarcerated and that was essentially it
you interact ended up actually seeing
his character killed off in the tadahasi
codes incredible hulk run and as far as
i'm aware he hasn't really been seen
since there was a bit of a revamping of
the character with new avengers
after secret wars that was led by robert
decosta uh that story kind of sucked
and that version of the red hulk wasn't
very good at all but for the most part
general thunderbolt ross as the red hulk
has basically
been gone this entire time now if i'm a
betting man they're gonna bring him back
and the return of red hulk is going to
coincide with the introduction of the
red hulk in the mcu that's usually why
you see characters like that taken off
the table
is because they're going to be brought
back at some future point in time what
that time happens to be i don't really
know what he's going to look like we
have no earthly clue but at the end of
the day
that's just kind of the bit of a run
down history now if you want more
in-depth stuff with regards to to the
incredible hulk at least more in-depth
than we went here with regards to the
red hulk if you want more in-depth uh
story there you can actually find the
whole
incredible hulk run by greg pack which
includes everything we covered
involving the red hulk down in the
description right it's just this massive
great big huge series of videos that we
made i want to say it's like nine hours
long right
it's nuts i think it's the longest full
story video that we have it's
crazy how huge it is but it covers all
the red hulk stuff but for an explained
video that we usually try to keep under
half an hour
uh we did a pretty good job i think
there's just
a lot that happened with the red hulk in
a really long in a really short period
of time
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]